Ah, but hello, I'm
still very nervous because it's my first time making a full-scale presentation like this. As you can
see,
I'm going to
present about functional JavaScript in this session.  I
came to this place because I wanted to purchase the experience of getting a little bit of a sense while applying some of the attributes of the actual project.
But I am currently developing a front-end for a company called Lunisi, which analyzes medical images.
It's my 3rd year.
Before that, I was designing.
Three years ago, when I just started learning development, it was 2016. At
that time, there was a very hot keyword that came to mind.  Even if there are
some people who haven't used it, there are probably few people who haven't heard of it. It
is a library that continues to be loved as much as that.
And 3 years ago, there was another keyword that came to mind along with Iriet,
which is Redux.
This special child is also being compared a lot, but at the time, this redux
was considered very innovative, so I
went to see it very earlier.
As you can see, it is the basic structure of
Redux that separates the state from gray and the interface and changes the state with actions.
But again, with this Redux,
there is a keyword that has been sneaking around little by little, but it's not until I came up with it. It
was functional programming.
It was said that it was
created by bringing ideas from Elm, a functional language, so the
keyword ‘functional’ was mentioned little by little with Redux.
Still, I didn't understand all of the concepts behind it, but
using Redux itself was very enjoyable and fun.
When creating an app following the structure of Redux like this, all interests
were naturally separated
and the code including components became very clean.  I liked Knox very much.
So, because of this love for Redux, I seem to
have a vague curiosity and longing for functional programming.  I
started a study with my colleagues.
In our study, you can learn many basic concepts about adventure swimming,
using pure functions, preventing side effects on sleep,
using preamble grammar, etc.
And I also
learned about monads and integral programs.
And in fact, the most memorable thing in this study is the advantages of writing it as function 0.
Now, since it connects simple pure functions, it is stable because there is little room to come or go within one function.  , and
then,
because it connects small functions, it has high usability in society
and it is easy to understand the upper level logic.
Something about Sooyoung came out with the feeling that it was just this.
Because when we actually write the code for the project, this is the
fish tank where we can apply what we learned in the study.
Therefore, when I write it, I think there was a
feedback saying, So this doesn't seem like one person, so I think you only had this information.  I
went and started a new project.
Yes, it's an app like this to show you simply.
Well, take a little while.
Add a grid like this, and
display which parts of the cell slide show cancer or what fat cells are, so that you can accumulate data.  This is a tool that helps.
I am given the task of refactoring this tool. Because previously,
only Eri's trap-up white bus was applied and the state management was
not organized, so I was given the task of refactoring using transfer theory.
And I naturally wrote the code using compiling as I continued to write in the past.
When using convoluted addresses, Uggle sees the states contained in juice
ares as a house for each domain and separates these addresses at all.
The connection between the order of things can be done through actions.
So, when we say that we
add a label like this on a screen like this, now, first of all, the
basics are
collecting only the core information.
When you write , you
need to use other label types or other information in the grid address.
And here, as the app becomes more complex, various information will be added.
All information must be passed as parameters as parameters.
And the more these actions are, the more likely the parameters will be very cartoony.
Then, there was one more thing that I didn't like.
In David
Ware, there is a b operation that handles
events that cause other side effects, and either handles events that cause other side
effects, or calls another action right away.
But
again, if Eagle is selected here again,
When writing such a reducer that goes in and
out, after writing a
lethal that goes out of the grid like this, in order to
call other actions simply
I believe in this kind of middleware function, you have to write the code.
And again, the more processing like this, the more unnecessary middleware function codes
like this.
After thinking about it for the first time, I looked at the Redux documentation, and here there
was an item called Compilation crazy, post-combining is already late.  It is
said that it can only cover kisses,
so it is said that some other custom logic is needed.
So, I can write each lease server code by calling it while minimizing the passing of function arguments,
and then in Redux middleware, the maximum booth
effect  I
started working now with the goal of writing and copying the
book of uh star and garris so that it can be different. Well, here is another fisherman to help me.
Introducing the library.
As you can see in the code, it is a synthesis function that makes various Leeds in turn into
one state in game 7. It is a
library. 4 This is Leeds Thrill Thrills official document.
Uh, if I
use this as it is, now I have to put it in the state, so now I
thought I should write it in a way that
synthesizes reducers like this to create the shape I want.  It
came out. If you look
through the documents, notices, and documents in history, there
are so many
libraries.  I want to
start with what I know, so I chose lambda.
Lambda js is a Hamshik-yang library whose main specialty is currying and compositing.  I
decided to mainly use this method, which
synthesizes each function in sequence called pipe 2. Synthesis of synthesized functions is the
main work process.  I used 4 pipes because I
thought it wouldn't be natural to read yesterday because it was half back,
so I used this composition to rewrite the reducer that went out of the grid earlier.
In this way, there is a separate reducer science, and
through the work ahead of the new year, I am finally making a reducer called Drag as I draw in Egypt.
And each of these ends
can be mapped to an action and used.
After seeing it as a function and writing it, it was naturally
thought that writing in this mapping form rather than a switch was more popular, so I
wrote it like this.  To show you how it is processed a little more,
I took the section called switch reducer like this, created a function that selects a reducer suitable for the action type from the map, and
used it to write a simple code in the form of finally creating a book tree order.  The
let us state state fashion is going over the same, but since the
action type information is not needed in the reducer that has already been selected according to the action type, in
this case, we have additionally changed it to pass on the lungs.
In the form of receiving,
the code has become a little simpler.
In this process, the
method that I was pouring yesterday was to combine all the estates into one and
write many Leeds books,
respectively.  The
structure was so powerful in Korean that it was only executed less. It
seems to be less. So, is this child talking about processing this way
? I
got a feeling a little yesterday while writing
this code.  If you
look at the juice written, it is
put at the bottom of the grid and each function
is one subtitle first, so you have to use the
duck first.
As you can see in this example code, now if
you wrap a function with a curry, it is a function that makes it possible to execute arguments to the function in sequence or put them all at once.
But if you change this, you
need to place it like that as shown below to see what happens to the same code.  In the
case of receiving the list later, it is
natural to put the argument called uh separate first, but
if the order is reversed like
this, a placeholder is put in to mean that it will be executed first.  I
found out that the order has a lot of influence.
So, if you look at it, in the functional type, it is written only in the form of how to connect several functions and
pass some data to it.  I think it
can be seen that it was written in the form,
but when I made it like this, I just wrote it inertia in the order in which I originally passed the street and payload in the 2nd base treez will.
As shown earlier in the 2 cheat grids below, you have
no choice but to use placeholders.
It's neat,
so while writing this code, I now
know in more detail why lambda js
says that kerlin and synthesis are cheats.
In this way, each of the
wrong factors is given a billion colors, then arranged
sequentially, then cut off the first 10, then summed up each and
divides them into 10 again.  If we
try to write it in dash with another famous library, it will be like this when we write it with basic load c.  You have
to put all the curry place holders.
Then, when loading, basically 5 lists or venue
why data are 5 in the front.
So
why can lambda come out so neatly about this?
And then, as
shown earlier, this is because the order of parameters is optimized for language learning and synthesis.
And in the case of CeCi, it provides a separate rival called Jerrod cfp with this in mind.  Control
method
Now, it is written in such a way that other factors are passed first and data is passed last.
If
you look at it, the code has been reduced by almost 3/4, and it is
written so that one function can be written, and the functions necessary for the edge grid are written so that
simple functions
are not stored separately in 0 Trust Air and Reducer, so that you can immediately understand the logic in one place.
So I think that if I write more code lead third like this, the code will be
reduced more and the width will be not neat.  I came to
have a lot of affection for the word c Lang, our only operation, and then for Kerin and Composition Synthesis, and
I was very satisfied.  It
was a pattern that
draws the actual drawing part in the app earlier.  If you
look at it, you
get 10 campus context.
Now, if you look at the small part once more, if you
look at the part that adds a new guide to the grid, it is
written like this.
When I saw the functions that perform each necessary function of the context, I am binding all the contexts here.
The amount has become a bit like this, so a huge chunk came. It
was fine when this was a state, but since we
used the same data for each context handling function that
didn't matter, this ridiculous data structure came out.
At that time, it
was a little difficult to figure out what kind of logic it was compared to different functions. At
this time, I
recalled the former who told me a lot
about the function queen.  He said, "Let's find out how to find."
So, I started looking for it. Diversity seems to be a more familiar concept in the class now.
So, when I
searched for how to implement this function around 3 o'clock, this concept is
not even a concept of a nurse disk screen h or a union.  If you
look at our top script document, you divide the kind and
put the rest of the information you need now. If you
try and scroll under it, you will see this code.
Through the switch, different functions are executed according to the kind of data type.  It must be the
code you have seen a lot. It
is the structure of each reducer of the action type used in Redux.
So, through this search process, I
was vaguely thinking about something like this that Redux was designed based on the function yog earlier, and then came up with
some concept more.  Now I know that it was borrowed,
so I thought that I had to write the campus using the child concept, and
I wrote it for some reason.
Looking
at the part that draws only a new grid guide partially in my entire grid logic earlier,
uh,
here is a function that creates data,
uh, sorry, and 1 function for vehicle operation is
attached to the logic.
I did because in the functional type, it
is said that there are basically 5 loosely coupled data and functions,
so if you look at it, in gas-oriented programming, it is very strongly coupled through classes.
Well,
when I looked at the top logic of this whole logic, now I looked like this.
When I
looked at the function haha
gastric cancer surgery in the details I saw earlier, there was also a form called data attached
here.  Even in the function, the draw state and the compass context
are the structure that I and the data method feel the same and pass on, so I did a skill to stand.  I'm
going to have to drop this guy a little bit.
Now I'm thinking that I was coding against 1 pipe with a structure that fits the class, so I
changed it to this structure.
By doing so, I
made the effects to be finally passed on with the data, and then
changed the entire header hole by applying it to the campus context at once, but I
came to work on this.  It's
similar, it was separated like this, and
then the basic Tektro functions, which were so full of curries,
were
organized very neatly.  In the drawing part, there is
now a function that creates data, and then
function 1 that receives data and executes the nucleus has been piped,
but it has also been changed to a function that processes only data first,
so the 4 final function also has a
little context binding  has been done,
and the text king data has not been separated.
Now, in the newly created function, it has been changed in this way to create a different function only for the data, and
finally apply it to Computex Tear.  , and
then it was deployed.
Uh, very strangely, it was deployed, and how this was so many.
- 3 more Schumanns occurred. Arthur, what I
can see again here is that when we first learned about functional types, uh, it is
the best among the advantages that came out now, so
I feel very much about the stability of this business.  And
then, since each of the functions was written and written, the reusability was
very high. Since I took it from redux to one state,
all selectors can be reused in reuse, so I can reduce a lot of code conflicts.
But now, the final  As
for the ease of recognizing the logic, I have a bit of a
hard time with the tone, because I haven't written before, but among the codes I wrote, there are
quite a few codes that use methods that can only be found in functional types, such as functions called convergence or functions called transfers.
So now, I think that it takes a little more effort for other people to understand, maintain, and
understand, so I gave 2 triangles because that part was covered.
This is the first synthesis, and I continued to write while learning the concepts of scrimming hd union.  Let's
go Function name Now I feel that it is the key in the program
4 My presentation is here.